[Música]
de cara a las elecciones de medio
término de noviembre en las que se
pondrá en juego el control del congreso
de eeuu por parte de los demócratas cae
la popularidad de job aiden entre su
electorado más de cinco mil migrantes
permanecen en los centros de recepción
migratoria de darién entre colombia y
panamá los cortes de vías derivados de
las protestas antigubernamentales que
continúan hace semanas impiden su flujo
por territorio panameño
cerca de cumplir un año como presidente
de perú pedro castillo obtiene una
desaprobación del 74 por ciento la
segunda cifra más alta después de la de
abril cuando su gobierno enfrentó
protestas antigubernamentales y el
mandatario decretó el toque de queda en
lima y callao
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de france 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias del
continente americano soy santiago y te
comenzamos esta emisión en eeuu el
control del congreso por parte de los
demócratas está en juego en las próximas
elecciones de medio término y crecen
ciertas dudas en el electorado demócrata
sobre la capacidad de la actual
administración del presidente de joe
biden que enfrenta una crisis mundial y
muchos reveses políticos rafael pérez
nos cuenta más en este informe
un descontento visible en los votantes
demócratas mientras las elecciones de
medio término se acercan cae en la
popularidad de joe biden con varias
crisis internas que han puesto a prueba
su capacidad de respuesta existen dudas
en el electorado
creo que todo el liderazgo demócrata
incluido el presidente debería ser más
despiadado en lo que respecta a luchar
por lo que quieren porque los
republicanos son minoría y logran lo que
quieren porque no tienen miedo a luchar
sucio ya veces hay que jugar sucio para
proteger los derechos de la gente
las elecciones del próximo noviembre se
leerán como un plebiscito de los
primeros dos años del inquilino de la
casa blanca varios temas influenciarán
las decisiones de los estadounidenses la
inflación la mayor en 40 años el alto
precio de los combustibles provocado por
la invasión a ucrania y la lucha de
mandatos con el poder judicial que han
marcado la culminación de una etapa
señalada por la emergencia sanitaria el
aborto y las armas aspectos en los que
no se pueden buscar consensos
partidistas alfio del instuto
siento que todavía está intentando
apelar a ambos lados en cualquier asunto
y esa no es realmente una opción en este
punto
sin embargo hay quien lo apoya en
cualquier circunstancia
me gusta mucho yo bailén y realmente
encuentro que está haciendo un gran
trabajo no entiendo por qué todos se
quejan de lo que está haciendo el bajo
índice de aprobación es una tendencia
que se repite de las administraciones
trump y obama con que ambos no
enfrentaron una crisis mundial como la
actual
y en otras noticias en más de cinco mil
migrantes permanecen en los centros de
recepción migratoria de darién entre
colombia y panamá los cierres de vías
provocados por las protestas
antigubernamentales que sacuden al país
hace semanas han impedido el flujo de
los migrantes en territorio panameño
algunos manifestantes anunciaron que
radicalizarán la protesta a partir del
próximo lunes ampliamos la información
con nuestro corresponsal oscar sulbarán
la directora del servicio nacional de
migración de panamá a samira gozaine
informaba la tarde de este domingo que
de más de 5 mil migrantes permanecen
varados en la provincia de darién el
tránsito de vehículos con migrantes que
se revisa a diario desde el extremo de
la frontera con colombia hasta el lado
de la frontera con costa rica se ha
visto afectado por los cierres de las
vías debido a las protestas que viven
panamá por estos días hay incertidumbre
en lo que puede ocurrir durante este fin
de semana el gobierno nacional sostuvo
dos mesas de diálogo paralelas ambas en
el interior del país en una de ellas
logró un acuerdo con dirigentes
indígenas se logró abrir la carretera en
la provincia de darién fronteriza con
costa rica pero horas más tarde
volvieron los cierres pues las bases de
esa hacer comunidades indígenas
rechazaron el acuerdo acuerdo que por
cierto también fue criticado por el
gremio de educadores que mantenía la
otra mesa de diálogo con el gobierno un
tercer grupo de asociaciones y
sindicatos se reclaman que no han sido
tomados en cuenta y amenazan con
radicalizar la protesta
de este lunes además de los migrantes
varados en darién ya los efectos de los
bloqueos de las vías comienzan a
sentirse en varias zonas del país donde
ya se han reportado
desabastecimiento de rubros alimenticios
y gasolinas y la repatriación de los 53
migrantes centroamericanos que perdieron
la vida y nunca habían abandonado en
texas el mes pasado continúan y dentro
de esas víctimas 10 eran adolescentes
como pasqual melvin watt jacques y para
un guatemalteco de 13 años que fue
enterrado el sábado en el municipio de
nahualá
familiares y amigos dijeron adiós por
última vez a pasqual melvin watt jacques
y para que el adolescente indígena de
tres años es el primer repatriado de los
21 guatemaltecos de la tragedia de texas
en eeuu el 27 de junio un empleado
municipal de san antonio encontró a 67
personas asignadas en un camión
sobrecalentado 48 de ellas que ya habían
fallecido por asfixia y me llamara como
a las cinco y media de la tarde y medio
uno compañero llegó a tu hijo no
y no es por su estado de verdad
la noticia que pasó una tragedia que se
[Música]
investigue me dijo
en ese momento empecé a investigarlo
investigadas que intentan llamar su
celular que ya no contesta en minuto
también ya los cortes
y cabal que llevan en el tráiler desde
entonces las autoridades tratan de
identificar a cada una de las víctimas
para entregarlas a sus familias los
cuerpos de 25 de los 26 migrantes
mexicanos fallecidos ya llegaron a su
país dentro de los que están los de
estos tres primos de la localidad de san
marcos a tex y lapa no buscaban emigrar
a eeuu para encontrar un trabajo un
mejor remunerado si el trabajo del
mexicano es tan preciado en los eeuu no
es válido hacerlo de manera ilegal no es
válido que ellos caminen para la derecha
y la autoridad golpe para la izquierda
en centroamérica la repatriación de los
cuerpos de las víctimas de texas se
espera que termine en los próximos días
según la organización internacional para
las migraciones desde 2014 unos seis mil
430 migrantes han muerto o desaparecido
en su camino en busca del llamado sueño
americano
vamos ahora hasta perú porque el
presidente de pedro castillo cumplirá
hacia finales del mes su primer año al
frente del ejecutivo y lo hará con la
desaprobación en su segundo punto más
alto desde que fuera investido y es que
el 74 por ciento de los peruanos rechaza
su gestión en france 24 día lo vamos con
rené su dieta para ccoo o analista
político de periodista sobre qué ha
llevado a esta cifra de desaprobación y
también sobre los retos que enfrenta al
castillo para intentar revertir esta
situación
bueno el presidente llega a esta cifra
de esta aprobación
con algunos problemas en gobierno no
solo a nivel de gestión sino también a
nivel judicial porque enfrenta tres
investigaciones pero eliminar es en la
thalía
dos de ellas en dos de ellas tres indica
pertenecer a una organización criminal
tenemos también una problemática social
debido a la crisis externa el incremento
de los combustibles pero relacionando un
poco digamos el contexto en el que llega
esta situación y la encuesta por ejemplo
encuesta señala que la mayoría está
preocupada por lo que es en seguridad
ciudad pues es justamente este es uno de
los retos lo que también tiene el
presidente el adelantado que va a hacer
un anuncio una sorpresa es un mensaje de
por primer año del gobierno esa
incertidumbre también expuesta no y en
medio de una crisis financiera mundial
provocada por la guerra en ucrania y la
incertidumbre global las inversiones
están cayendo en brasil el país que
reúne a la mayoría de las startups de la
región se enfrenta a una cascada de
despidos en este sector el informe es de
gabriel cushion
brasil el país de las empresas
emergentes de américa latina se enfrenta
a una cascada de despidos en sus tartas
el país reúne el mayor número de
unicornios en la región ya que cuenta
con 20 startups tecnológicas
valoradas en más de 1000 millones de
dólares pero en los últimos meses se han
registrado alrededor de 1.000 despidos
en estos unicornios sin contar las otras
empresas del sector la explicación sólo
en el primer semestre del año hubo una
reducción del 40 por ciento de las
inversiones en el país
este es un movimiento mundial no sólo en
brasil vemos un cambio muy grande en la
economía global un aumento en las tasas
de interés en casi todos los países y
esto hace que los inversores migran de
inversiones más riesgosas a otras menos
riesgosas esto afecta a la disposición a
invertir en startups por ejemplo aún
para ver si en startups pues la causa
los efectos de la guerra en ucrania el
conflicto ha generado una triple crisis
mundial alimentaria energética y
financiera
y creo un ambiente de incertidumbre que
aleja a los inversores de los mercados
las startups que antes buscaban crecer
lo más rápido posible aunque no
generaban beneficios ahora tienen que
dar prioridad a sus ganancias sin
embargo por el tamaño de su mercado
brasil sigue estando en el punto de mira
de los inversores extranjeros y el
sector sigue creciendo aunque más lento
es todo por el momento regresamos en
breve con más noticias y ganen france24
[Música]